[音楽]
dare
ああああああ
[音楽]
[拍手]
ああああああああ
[笑い]
[拍手]
[音楽]
goo
ああああああ
car
ふーん
ああああああ
ええええええ
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
ああああああ
ああった
goo
ああ
ああああああ
[音楽]
me
ああああああん
ああああああ
皆さんこんにちはをマイクでかいんじゃ
笛の演奏が当社水泡と申します
今日は皆さんが最近非常に気になっている話題
何ですかふえっありがとうございますね
うえお話ですねさせていただきたいと思います気になってますかねえ
郷土の船持っているが消えようとか
この川に30本あるかなっ
いないそうなことを知って今から皆さん気になっていると思います
まあそうですね笛という言葉
まあ福江だという言葉が変わったらしいですよ腹鳴ダフネ増え
イベントなったらしいですよ
生きてるやってますね
今日はそうですね私の自己紹介からまずさせていただきます
私は
まあ2ウェイの増加ですけれども
基本的には家具キー音楽というもの中心
演奏を活動しています
なぜたーーーーとか簿記はずキロもとと言ったじゃんにも音楽
みなさん聞いて
ございますか
まあ対していないですよねあの末も仕方ないといえば仕方ない
娯楽が今多様化してまこした伝統音楽はもう
古典芸能年頭ガッキー起こした方に触れ合う機会というのは
普通に生活している中ではほとんどない
と言って差し支えないと思います
まあそんな中なので私たち実演家もなるべく
皆さん
古典減の中で通り a のそういったものを知ってもらうための活動
幅広く皆取り組んでいます
マーサの中で私といいますとバイオリン
洋楽のバイオリンと伝統和額貴公子た物細グレートした
4人組ユニット
これであのクレーター活動をしてきました
まああのこの活動はジャズとか先ほどもうちょっとじゃうっているとジャズとか
ポップスロックそうしたものに伝統楽器の響きを
せまあいろんな方に知ってもらおうというまずは知ってもらうための活動ではあります
まあこの活動成果を上げ始めてメジャーレーベル
から2枚のアルバムをリリースしました
そして現在では日本全国また海外でのパフォーマンスの機会も非常に増えてきました
まあこうしたまぁちょっとあ
なんていうかわかりやすい活動っていうものを伝統芸能を知っている方からすると
ちょっと
is だとしている溢れてるんじゃないかなっていうふうに見られてしまう向きもある
んですが
まあ今の世の中にはした新やすいこと
わかりやすいことというのは非常に重要でもあり
まあそれとできれば古典芸能の本来の魅力
5社も一緒に伝えられればなと思って活動しています
沿って皆さん
伝統だは団がイメージでしょうか
菓子から変わらない
昔のままの姿を厳格に守ったものこそ伝統なんというふうに思いでしょうか
まあここで伝統というものをちょっと考えてみたいんですがまぁか不器用例にとって
考えてみたいと思います
歌舞伎2型のは長い歴史の中で男性の気による演劇表現という道をありを抜きました
まあそういう中で
男性の役者が女性を演じることもありそれをどうするべきか
歌舞伎俳優たちは考えました
その中で女性脱した後証言するためにある時は受精よりも女性らしいシーブさを追求し
最後まで研究しそれを体系化して形というものをつくった
カダーというのはスタイルでもありますねまあそうした
伝えるほかにも男性足
荒事の方
まあですとか他にも台詞回し舞台表現
音楽なんかにもかた後も作って歌舞伎を芸能としてまー
整理させていったんです
香月がこの形というものを持ったことによって
まあ様々なまあ銃弾が m を取り入れることができるようになりました
方を持っているからこそ伝統芸能として成立していったわけです
ここで話を直現代に戻しますが最近
カパの開学を主役にした有名な漫画作品
ございますね
これを歌舞伎化して大きな話題を呼びました
こういうイメージはだけますけれどもあの
この
舞台はですね最新の照明設備等
まあ複雑な舞台人とそうした現代的な舞台なんです
まあこうした現代的なものが本当に伝統ゲーム
貨物と呼べるのが説くところはすごく疑問に思う方もいらっしゃるかもしれません
まあただし先ほどお話ししたとか武器には方というものがあります
まあこの方に当てはめれば現代的な題材も歌舞伎化できる
まあこういったことの証左になっているかと思います
まあそのためには役者陣制作陣が心の中からだの中に十分
古典作品で培った方の
精神性芸術性そういったものが新婚でいるということも大事なポイントです
まあそしてこの作品だけどいいました
話題になったんです
revo で実はこの話題性についてお話ししたいと思います
伝統芸能と話題性
これはどういう組み合わせかなと思われる方もいるかもしれません
実はでも粘投芸能である歌舞伎にとって話題性での非常に重要な要素だった
話題をするのはまぁ一般の人々です
その
歌舞伎で言えば
もともと歌舞伎を支持し未だにしてきたら
江戸の町民たちでした
超問題でしたね
江戸の町民たちに受けるために必要な様子は娯楽性話題性だったんですね
歌舞伎は娯楽性を高めるために
巷で話題の
いう衝撃的な心中事件
ましたあの事件
いち早く演目に取り入れたりあるいはは誰もファッ車
あとは流行からそういったものを柔軟に演目に取り込むきました
まあこうして人々の話題になり
まぁあとはそうですね三味線と言う餓鬼今では古臭いネーションをしかもしれませんが
この楽器も当時は江戸に入ってきたわかる最新の楽器だったのです
こんな感じで江戸時代が歌舞伎っていうのは伝統型脳ではありながら
非常にポップ感チャー取り入れた
そんな芸能んだったんですね
まあ先ほどの漫画作品をポップかぼちゃ
まあこれを取り入れで各帰化したとそれがあるな話題になっていること
これはわずか3台時間ということですねこの話題が話題性が続けばまあそんな作品が
また一人とに支持され
上演を繰り返すことになります
場外を繰り返すとさらにその舞台は専念されていきます
そうすると
もしかしたら100年200年後の先には
校舎作品が古典作法として愛されている可能性もあるので
pandan
歌舞伎という芸能のすごいよ思う
これは方という芸術先生申請
これを確かに受け継いで現代まで続いていること
まあと同時に人々の支持を集め
そして娯楽性維持し
現代も
この現代の社会にも歌舞伎という伝統芸能が生きているということが非常に大切なん
です
まあ少しネットゲームについてご理解いただきましたでしょうか
まあここで逆に私から皆さんに質問したいんですけれども
皆さんにとっては伝統型脳はどんな存在です
あんまで関わり合いがない方が多いんですけれども
まあ
うーん言うな
皆さんの家の庭に
大きな木があるとしてください
ご実感お隣の公園のようですご実家のたが声に古くて大きいが1000人が育て
タッキーがあるとします
まあこれが伝統芸能の木だと思ってください
まあこのキーを育てて
まあ
未来につなぐことこれは何時代の
人々も資産になるのではないかと私は考えています
ああそうですネットゲーの大きい
まあし頃特段気にすること困っちゃうじゃねぇんですよ
シボのためだに意識することがなくているんですよ
意識することはなくてもふと振り返った瞬間心のよりどころになったり
もしかしたらアイデンティティーの源になるそんな方もいるかもしれません
まあこの本伝統芸能のキーをですね私たちは先人が育てた太い幹
高い梢
そんな気から可能性という名の枝葉を伸ばし
日の当たるところが出ていくという努力
そんな絞るとをしています
できることが皆さんにもこの木を愛し
伝統芸能の木を気にかけていただき
まあ
しかし彼に水えお
そういった形でレントゲンを見守っていただけたらなぁと私の願いでございます
さて最後にほんの少しだけでも1000人みんな育てた
古典芸能少しだけまた返送させていただきます
私パフォーマンス様々する中でもなるべく古典作品から
エッセンスをもらうようにしています
先人が育てたその偉大な古典サクソン
もう力ず
モークの深さそうしたものを少しでも皆さんにお伝えできればなと思います
うん
あーうーうー
ああああああ
[音楽]
ふーん
[拍手]
[音楽]